[Music]
you've spent a part of your career a
good chunk of it making men suffer - in
movies like yes torturing them and
getting paid for it
yes mess yeah I'm just curious about
that like is that first of all it's I'd
be done with that you know I think
captured by Maggie Q but I like to see
men suffer a little bit at the hands of
a woman because you guys you know you
kind of deserve a little it's funny
the women cheered and the men were also
like we do we're bad guys no I think
it's true I think yeah I feel people
don't complain too much when a woman's
punishing a man yeah yeah women hurting
men is better than girl-on-girl no no no
it's just fine hitting other women yeah
it's not as tasteful hitting but
wrestling and hellos when they're
hitting each other with pillows yeah
because we do that right yeah they do
that's how women settle their arguments
in my imagination Irish is that right I
am almost half what is the Irish name
that you wait Quigley Quigley yeah
really
Margaret Quigley Margaret yeah don't I
look like one yes yes do you do you like
st. Patrick's Day is coming up is that
important to you st. Patrick's Day I
mean I gone you out on st. Patrick's Day
and I give them my ID and it says
quickly and they look at me like I'm not
a quickly right but I am but I am but I
am right you just punch him real hard
right exactly
no Irish I am then they'll be requited
you just moved to upstate New York mm is
that great and tell us about this you
moved kind of to the middle of nowhere I
like the woods I like nature and I liked
seeing no one and you like seeing no
this is a joy for you right now
I hate being around people and
backgrounds like but you like your
privacy and you like to just get get
away I do I mean I I love people I don't
want to seem like a total recluse but I
I do I love nature and I might you know
if my dogs are happy I'm happy so I sort
of live you know I have a nice little
forest and I have a river that runs
under my house and it's all very
peaceful it's just a newer house or is
it like an old no it's almost 300 years
old 300 years old okay we'll have a
couple questions first of all are you
okay being there by yourself
I have German Shepherds so that's
awesome so I don't use right not German
man there just want to make sure good
job cuz I like to visual I was free I
went the other way to go